les questions que se posent les français
sur l'école et y en a énormément
monsieur le ministre les masses mon
style s'inscrire dans la durée dans nos
écoles est ce qui va encore avoir des
masques encore longtemps ça c'est la
question qui revient tout le temps sur
les réseaux c'est normal c'est cette
question on a tous envie que ça finisse
bien sûr on ne peut plus mari un an le
jour on commencera arrêté sera on
commencera sans doute par l'école
primaire et puis ensuite par par
l'enseignement secondaire c'est qu'entre
les conditions sanitaires le slam est
rien il ya une gagnée chiant ça ou pas
du tout non c'est impossible à dire on a
fait un procès quatre protocoles vous
savez là on est dans le protocole 2 donc
si on est capable à un moment donné de
descendants le protocole 1 ça voudra
dire qu'on on pourra dans le centre et à
l'emballage et pour l'instant ça ne
serait pas serait pas raisonnable c'est
quoi il va jusqu'à au moins jusqu'au 20
décembre ou bien ce sera mon c'est
vraiment impossible à dire vous savez on
regarde l'évolution là par exemple en ce
moment la situation est plutôt bonne
s'agissant du pays vient dans la
population générale puisque sa baisse
depuis plusieurs jours donc si ça
continue positivement on peut imaginer
des allégements mais c'est trop tôt
c'est trop tôt au moment où on ferme
plus de classe puisque c'est toujours
comme ça d'ailleurs après les après les
vacances donc c'est en train de monter
j'espère que ça va s'arrêter parce que
c'est la courbe il ya toujours ce que
c'est un truc de fou parce qu'en fait le
protocole soit l'un des cols et plein de
classe fermée le protocole et il est
extrêmement dur ici entre deux eaux et
bien sûr mais il est fait pour nous
protéger donc il est extrêmement
exigeant puisqu'on ferme dès qu'il ya un
cas assez ça donc c'est comme ça qu'on a
dépassé le cap des 3000 de la dernière
il nous arrive est monté jusqu'à 8000
donc c'est possible ça fait jamais que 0
5% c'est grâce à ça qu'on peut aussi
ouvrir tout le reste est pour l'instant
la rentrée scolaire ne se traduit pas
par par un changement dans la dans la
baisse d'accord que je reste pour
l'instant pour l'instant l'emea ce qui
vaut pour l'instant les masques on va
garder les masques la vaccination pour
les enfants ne sera t-elle vraiment
jamais obligatoire
alors ça aussi ça fait partie des
questions auxquelles on peut on peut pas
répondre de façon certains parce qu'il
ya des études en ce moment dans
internationale pour regarder l'intérêt
de faire cela ça n'est pas du tout à
l'ordre du jour actuellement peut-être
que ça le serait dans le futur en plus
il peut y avoir d'autres variantes
d'autres raisons de faire ainsi mais
pour l'instant c'est ses 12 ans et plus
et 12 ans et plus mais normalement fin
ça ne devrait pas changer avant quelques
temps d'accord alors ça c'est vrai que
sénèque donc pour l'instant ça va rester
comme ça est-ce que maxime sur le rivage
c'est vraiment un sujet des autres un
sujet comme celui là c'est un mec j'ai
écrit des autorités sanitaires qui sur
ça ne dépend pas de moi c'est de et à
l'échelle mondiale puisque saison il ya
des études pour voir l'effet que ça sur
les enfants l'intérêt que ça représente
puisque les enfants au moins de
symptômes que les autres donc c'est
quelque chose qui se décideraient si à
l'échelle mondiale notamment
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
considéré qu'il fallait faire mais pour
l'instant c'est pas du tout à l'ordre du
jour à une autre question pourquoi les
profs n'ont pas la vaccination
obligatoire comme d'autres métiers ça
aurait pu être le cas mais il se trouve
que c'est une profession où la
vaccination volontaire est très forte on
a dépassé maintenant les 90% on était à
89 % il ya d'après une étude qu'on a
fait il ya trois semaines d'accord est
actuellement les le vaccin est proposé
au professeur et à tous les adultes
d'ailleurs qui travaillent dans les
établissements en même temps qu'on me
propose aux collégiens et aux lycéens
donc tant qu'à faire autant ce soit sur
la base du volontariat et c'est ce qu'on
a fait alors il ya une question qui
revient aussi souvent est ce que vous
êtes favorable au halal dans les
cantines scolaires vous savez moi je
suis savoir la neutralité du service
public donc je pense qu'elle va plus
plus la question religieuse mais pas un
sujet de différenciation entre les
enfants à l'école mieux c'est le sens de
l'école de la république alors là c'est
les communes qui sont dans les écoles
qui sont en responsabilité de salé
département pour les collèges et les
régions pour les lycées elles ont des
politiques un peu différente d'un
endroit à l'autre ce qui est important
c'est qu'on puisse avoir des choix ce
qui fait que chacun peut ensuite avoir
la paix cité par ne pas prendre de
viande dans un repas mais mais en tout
cas c'est important aussi que la
neutralité du service public soit
respecté alors vous avez des questions
autour de la table qui veut poser la
première question valérie bénaïm aline
vous à l'instance a été la rentrée
scolaire il ya quelques temps de ça on
vous a pointé du doigt pour une
déclaration vous avez fait justement sur
les allocations rentrée vous avez dit
que certaines familles utiliser ces
allocations notamment pour s'acheter des
télévisions est autre chose que pour
aider leurs enfants est ce que vous
regrettez ces propos ou est ce que vous
dites non non je suis absolument
d'accord est ce que j'ai dit et je ne
reviens pas là dessus en général
j'essaie d'être cohérent s'ils voulaient
le chacun sait que les allocations de
rentrée les familles en font des choses
différente selon chaque famille donc si
cette formule a pu heurter s'est passé
pas une formule à laquelle je tiens y
compris un ministre du gouvernement
il est revenu mais ce qu'il a dit
n'était pas contradictoire avec ce que
j'ai dit ce qu'il a dit au fond qui
pouvait comprendre qu'une famille
utiliser ça par exemple pour payer une
facture d'électricité d'arriérés et je
pense qu'il a eu raison de dire ça c'est
vrai
simplement soyons lucides sur le fait
que parfois par exemple certains père de
famille font des dépenses qui n'ont pas
de rapport avec avec la rentrée scolaire
de l'enfant donc je crois qu'il faut
être honnête et dire les choses mais moi
je regarde aussi ce qui se passe dans
d'autres pays où parfois on donne des
bons d'achat peut-être que ça peut venir
d'ailleurs en plus de la rentrée
scolaire je connais une mairie par
exemple à clichy-sous-bois où là la
mairie achète de la papeterie pour les
enfants et les distribuer équitablement
entre toutes les familles ouf il
faudrait toujours night
seconds ex a suscité de l'émoi parce qu
on a souvent faim on a cru entendre que
vous reprochez à ces familles de faire
autre chose avec l'art avec cet argent
là non mais je reproche rien personne je
constate qu' il peut y avoir des achats
qui sont pas pour les enfants avec
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire c'est
un droit que c'est un fait qui est
d'ailleurs pas documenté de manière
précise ni dans un sens ni dans l'autre
et quand j'ai fait cette déclaration
parce qu'on a coupé une phrase mais j'ai
expliqué qu'il fallait partir de
constats concrets pour voir comment on
pouvait faire mais ça fait partie des
sujets sur lesquels quand on compare
avec les pays étrangers on peut
progresser voyez quand au brésil lula
avait créé ce qu'on appelle la bolsa
familia c'est à dire le fait de donner
des moyens aux mères de famille c'est
est conditionnée au fait que les enfants
aillent à l'école en france on n'en est
pas là on n'a pas besoin de faire ça
mais c'est assez normal de toujours
veiller à l'intérêt de l'enfant mois on
prenait chacune de mes décisions et on
peut en discuter sur ce critère là
l'intérêt de l'enfant et donc c'est pour
ça que j'ai dit cela mais ce n'était pas
fait pour choquer c'est fait pour dire
comment on fait pour que les enfants
puissent être le mieux équipé possible à
l'accueil la rentrée vous êtes très
proche forcément à du président
maquereau ou voyez beaucoup choix qui a
jamais eu autant de candidats à
l'élection en cas celle qui va arriver
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire et
enfin que le conages les petits jeux que
le président macron qui au passage est
très beau vous
[Rires]
allô macha
avec bella connaît vraiment un très beau
président ça peut le dire s'est jamais
arrivé soit
7,1 mais pas dans es ce que j'ai voilà
ce que peut nous confirmer ce soir que
oui il sera quand il ne fera jamais
si je pose à kessel
budget
c'est la question bon alors allez-y
c'est la réponse va pas déléguer pour le
faire s'il doit le faire ça viendra est
ce que nous aurions évidemment pas bien
sûr qu'il le sait s'il veut être
candidat pendant il le dit il parle pas
de ça avec nous deux est d'accord qu'il
est moins bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
mais ce important
une question intéressante
guillaume poser une question beauté
rime à rien mais ça mais c'est bien vous
avez récemment changé de look m'a
énormément d'articles là dessus c'est
nous parler de votre barbe tout à
l'heure c'est alors moi j'aime beaucoup
comme ça c'est quelque chose de réfléchi
à votre part pour donner une image plus
décontractée en tant que ministre de
l'éducation c'est une bonne question et
son non non non pas du tout en fait je
me laisse pousser la barbe chaque été
c'est ce que je fais depuis longtemps
parce que c'est une façon de ceux de se
reposer et puis à la fin de l'été il ya
un petit référendum familiale pour
savoir si je la gardais jusque là cette
façon c'est pas cette fois ci parce que
quand on vous a vu revenir cet été je me
suis dit tu me lis est allé faire koh
lanta c'est vrai alors oui la belle moi
j'ai une question people ont dit vous
êtes le chouchou de brigitte matheron
macron pardon il vous aurait recommandé
à emmanuel macron but de caen jeudi
quinquennat est ce que vous comptez
quels sont vos rapports actuels avec l
est est ce que vous considérez que vous
lui devez votre notoriété en politique
votre longévité au gouvernement alors la
question va s'arrêter un moment
on est sur une question à vous inquiétez
pas monsieur mais nice à lorient sait
pas c'est pas une question people je
crois que c'est un fake elle qu'elle
avait en tant qu elle m'avait entendue à
la radio quand on ne se connaissait pas
encore et qu'elle avait apprécié ce que
j'avais dit et que donc elle en a parlé
à son mari et que c'est comme ça que
nous nous sommes connus avant l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 et vos rapports
actuels c'est quelqu'un de que
j'apprécie énormément je trouve une
qualité
d'ailleurs je pense que ça ça se voit
quand on la voit à la télévision
ailleurs c'est quelqu'un qui est très
gentil qui est très fine
mais contrairement aux autres femmes de
présidents est très discrète et n'a pas
eu vraiment de rôle en tant que première
dame et je pense qu'elle cherche
justement pas empiéter voyez par exemple
elle s'intéresse beaucoup au sujet
l'éducation mais là bien sûr on a fait
des choses ensemble un contrôle
harcèlement à l'école en particulier on
va on va continuer sur le sujet des
enfants malades aussi ses intérêts a
mobilisé mais elle et elle est toujours
respectueuse du domaine de chaque
ministre effectue assez agréable c'est
un mot vous allez apprendre à parler de
l'intérêt de l'enfant justement tout à
l'heure encore on a reçu la mairesse et
un enfant qui a été raccompagné par un
policier municipal parce que sa maman
n'avait pas à régler la facture de la
cantine parce que c'est une méthode que
vous approuvez ou que vous condamnez
alors j'ai entendu tout à l'heure de
quoi il s'agissait je pense qu'il faut
toujours viser l'intérêt de l'enfant
justement est ce qu'on peut comprendre
la position de chacun dans une affaire
comme comme celle ci pour ça que j'aime
mon avis moins on en parle mieux mais on
se porte pas ce qu'il faut c'est que
l'on va soit préservée de deux
polémiques dont on doit toujours
rechercher l'intérêt de l'enfant donc là
en l'occurrence qu'ils puissent manger
qu'ils puissent ne pas être embêté par
par les eaux après ils assurent normal
qu'on doive payer la cantine il faut
trouver une solution sociale mais
raymond slama choix de société sur moi
je coûte maintenant
formé à l'école c'est ça fonctionne en
vous êtes vous êtes récemment sous le
feu de des magazines people est ce que
vous vivez bien cette notoriété qui est
arrivé d'un coup est ce que ça vous
dérange d'être sur la une des magazines
people comme ça vous gêne au pardon je
pense pas l'être beaucoup autre que j'ai
pas trop vu mais le notoriété c'est un
sujet
qui vous arrive qu'en peu de temps après
avoir été ministre donc les gens vous
reconnaissent dans la rue c'est ça des
aspects sympathiques puisque les gens
sont souvent très gentils vous parle de
l'école moi à chaque fois que j'ai
quelques parle évidemment parle de de
l'école et j'aime bien ça en fait donc
c'est pas désagréable j'ai connu très
peu d'agressivité en réalité seriez
trice laitiers plus ministre à côté il
ya des avantages et des inconvénients à
ne plus être un peu ce sera servi
seulement fériés quoi à mon métier ses
professeurs mais encore la location à
redevenir professeurs mais bon vous
allez allez vous êtes vous allé
travailler sur la campagne des manuels
mac mon message eu six compagnies bien
évidemment concerné par ce n'est pas
encore du boulot pendant beaucoup
pendant pas mal de temps oui kelly oui
alors tout à l'heure on parlait du
harcèlement scolaire ensemble avec ce
que vous avez fait avec brigitte
battrons moi j'ai une question c'est on
assiste tous à des dérives sur les
réseaux sociaux
on découvre dans le livre oui et
justement j'aimerais savoir si vous
pensez que ça a un impact sur la vie
réelle des étudiants et est-ce que vous
avez des solutions à mener sur ce
problème là bas c'est un énorme sujet
bien sûr c'est le plus difficile on a
progressé sur le sujet de la lutte
contre le harcèlement mais on a encore
beaucoup de progrès à faire il ya le
harcèlement et le cyber harcèlement sur
le harcèlement on arrive à progresser en
ce moment est improbable qu'on appelle
phare qui on a expérimenté depuis
plusieurs années et qui maintenant est
la vocation à exister dans tous les
collèges et tous les lycées de france
depuis cette rentrée et qui fait que
chaque
établissement doit avoir des
ambassadeurs contre le harcèlement se
dire qu'on responsabilise les
adolescents dans le fait de repérer les
problèmes de harcèlement et apporter des
remèdes c'est très important ce que tout
le monde doit se responsabiliser là
dessus évidemment les chefs
d'établissements les professeurs des
adultes mais aussi les élèves eux mêmes
il ya des très belles choses qui se
passent dans des établissements
aujourd'hui pour lutter contre ça le
cyber harcèlement c'est encore plus
difficile de lutter contre ça parce que
ça dépasse la le cadre de
l'établissement mais déjà ces méthodes
là fonctionne un peu et on doit surtout
avoir la coopération des grandes
plateformes donc on parle avec facebook
avec certaines ont commencé à
faire des choses un peu intéressants
c'est le compte n'y est pas encore
instagram je sais que facebook va faire
des choses mais on doit aller beaucoup
plus loin pour éviter que la haine se
déverse comme ça et notamment sur des
mineurs et donc c'est un sujet très
grave qui peut mener jusqu'à jusqu'à des
suicides et à des graphismes et donc on
essaye de prendre ça à bras le corps
c'est un problème mondial ou si on en a
encore beaucoup de boulot et sont encore
boulot mais on est au numéro on est
vraiment désireux d'avancer les remparts
tenant sur cette question oui mathieu
hamelin ministre j'aime pas touchés et
zemmour mais j'aime l'ordre échanges
qu'on en manque beaucoup en france et
notamment dans l'école pardon ça devient
extrêmement violent on a peur d'aller à
l'école aujourd'hui ce n'était pas le
cas à mon époque il est pour le retour à
l'uniforme est ce que vous aussi moi
j'ai jamais eu de problème avec le
principe de l'uniforme pour pour
plusieurs raisons la première c'est que
on a un problème qui d'ailleurs était un
peu évoqué tout à l'heure c'est celui
des marques quand on apparaît même de
l'allocation de rentrée c'est à dire le
fait qu' il ya une concurrence à l'achat
de biens de consommation très cher entre
les enfants et puis on leur met dans la
tête des finalement des objectifs de de
se procurer tels vêtements de marque ou
tel objet de marquer ça c'est une très
mauvaise chose donc une vertu d'un habit
commencer celle la confection d'armes je
suis pourquoi alors monsieur pour que
les établissements soient libres de
pouvoir le faire et parce que je pense
qu'on peut pas faire ça si ya pas une
adhésion de la communauté sert des
parents d'élèves des élèves des adultes
j'ai moi même contribué à ce qu'un
établissement j'ai contribué à la
fondation qui est l'internât
d'excellence de sourdun l uniforme
aujourd'hui ils l'ont et c'est très bien
mais si demain on décide l uniforme pour
tous tout de suite je pense qu'ils
auraient beaucoup d'effets
contre-productif donc un voyage aller et
ça aurait un coût mais qu'on pourrait
assumer justement par courage si vous
rentrez vous
je suis je suis pour que ce soit basé
sur le volontariat avec ça se développe
parce que ça permet de lutter contre des
certain nombre de faits malgré l'égalité
vous avez suivi un petit peu la sphère
eric zemmour qui a été évincé de son
émission face à un infos sur ces nous
par décision du csa il dit que le
gouvernement veut le faire taire il le
sous-entend en tout cas il a un nouveau
sondage d'aujourd'hui qui le donnait à
10% d'intentions de vote quand eric
zemmour est dit que le gouvernement veut
le faire taire vous lui répondez quoi
c'est une contradiction dans les termes
puisque tout le monde entend parler lui
c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire en
ce moment oui donc c'est comme les gens
qui disent qu'on est en dictature qui
voulait une diversité d'opinions dans ce
pays c'est qu'il se sente très important
de très fort qu'il faut préserver comme
quelque chose de fondamental et précieux
c'est ça la république et la démocratie
c'est que tout le monde peut s'exprimer
et il peut s'exprimer chacun de 16 à
penser qu'il va être candidat
lui alors je pense oui je sais ce que je
comprends vous posez le candidat à la
présidentielle
vous fait peur pour emmanuel macron pas
du tout moi je suis très démocrate donc
je pense qu'il est important d'avoir une
diversité d'expressions savoie et une
voix parmi d'autres et il est normal
qu'ils s'expriment d'accord comprenait
la décision du csa de le oui alors je
n'ai pas trop vocation à la commenter
mais je n'ai pas non plus regarder de
très près mais il me semble c'est assez
normal que si des personnes vont être
candidat à l'élection présidentielle il
ya les mêmes règles du jeu qui
s'applique pour eux pour tout le monde
parce qu'il n'a pas encore été alors je
pense que je n'ai qu'un débat autour de
ça mais voilà c'est ça parce que c'est
vrai que voilà aujourd'hui ne sait pas
encore mais a réussi à présenter voilà
mais bon tout quatre pour l'instant il
est out de ses douze lits sur la pièce
du corona y de monde qu'ils soient
affrontés il ya les scientifiques et les
politiques et c'est vrai que certains
ministres donc se verront kim in kyung
kim médecin était plutôt pour la
fermeture la roue à faire autour des
écoles etc on peut opposer avoué school
et rival avec le mini de la santé dans
cette crise alors comment on est amis
bons sons sont
bien sûr c'est qu'il faut ministre
mais la lazio et je m'en fous ces
limites ne vaut pas ce cas des mecs et à
dire qu'elle a des potes tous les
adhérents soit oui bien sûr je vais
parler ce matin par exemple j'aime
beaucoup de jacqueline gourault pour
vous donner un exemple ouais mais où
j'étais avec roselyne bachelot tout à
l'heure enfin voyez c'est déjà une bonne
ambiance oui je trouve il y avait
renoncé après il est normal c'est
classique que entre deux domaines il
puisse y avoir du flottement de la
discussion mais c'est logique et nous en
a ça nous arrive d'avoir des points de
vue différents c'est normal vous qui
l'avez gagnée mais et veyran avait un
beau bras quand elles étaient
vaccinés c'était beau mais c'est pas
possible
c'est incroyable
moix bonsoir monsieur ministre ont
souhaité rencontrer dans cette rémission
oui comment il fait lui aussi
mais bon c'est vrai que tu as les corps
les palais mais je sais pas si vous ne
trouvez pas qu'il ressemble un petit peu
à boris vian fin c'est une parenthèse
j'ai toujours trouvé que emmanuel macron
avait une ressemblance film avec en
prime un boris vian des noms très donné
lors on ne voit pas
les vire ont
le sentiment qu un ministre autant été à
sa place dire qu'on a l'habitude on aime
bien en france qu'à ses du politique et
je dois avouer que je crois que dans la
vème république on a rarement vu un
ministre dont on sentait qu'il était
attenant à sa place vous ne vous êtes
pas laissé impressionner par ce qu'on
appelle le mammouth vous avez réussi à
slalomer avec les syndicats vous avez
pris à bras le corps la réforme du
baccalauréat et de l'âme et de la glisse
et voulait manger chez le promu j'ai une
question à vous n'avez pas été aidé il
est vrai par le comité on a l'impression
quand même que les écoliers les
étudiants sont perturbés que parfois les
frontières sont poreuses entre la
première la terminent à la seconde il
sera pas tellement où il se trouve et où
ils habitent et très honnêtement on peut
aussi de temps en temps décerné à
certains ministres des lauriers et je
crois que vous êtes fait pour cette
fonction et que d'une certaine manière
vous l'avez honorer ma question est
quand même un peu pernicieuse dans
l'aviron et à titre personnel elles
arrivent à quelle heure la nation
j'adore du même si effectivement vous
avez réussi à des mathématisée balade
talent aura pour replacer la littérature
au coeur de l'enseignement et tout ça
m'a beaucoup plu et en même temps j'ai
eu une déception a condamné à moins que
ce soient des bruits de couloir j'ai cru
comprendre que vous étiez déçu de ne pas
voir le ministère de l'intérieur a et
c'est un peu décevant de du point de vue
de ceux qui vous soutiennent parce qu'on
se dit il incarnait tellement ce
ministère pourquoi est-ce qu'il a eu la
tentation finalement ou la déception de
ne pas aller à l'intérieur c'est une
bonne question oui elle est très longue
parce qu'elle me permet de clarifier je
vois écrit ça en permanence mais c'est
faux c'est à dire que je n'ai jamais
demandé le ministre sont atterrés chiba
a le droit aussi de vouloir lui et
devrait se charger convocation mais en
l'occurrence où la réalité factuelle
c'est que quand y'a un remaniement le
président et avec le premier ministre à
fait libre de vous proposer quelque
chose donc l'idée que je puisse devenir
miss de l'intérieur elle a circulé en
effet il a pu la formule mais c'est tout
mais moi je n'ai jamais demandé ça et
quand il en a été question j'ai dit que
je préférais le ministère n'aurait pas
une prise au ministère où ça il faut
inscrire pas comment le président
république pense que vous êtes utile
dans une fonction je trouve que c'est
normal et loyale que de l'accomplir mais
moi je n'étais pas du tout demandeur de
partir de l'éducation nationale puisque
comme vous l'avez rappelé depuis le
début j'ai dit que je souhaitais rester
tout au long du quinquennat et c'est pas
pour rien que j'y suis resté d'ailleurs
j'ai pas je me suis pas j'ai pas cherché
avec ministre de l'internet sinon vous
plairait pas donc à un moment donné on
est intellectuellement
actuellement bah oui le cas échéant le
moment venu mais en tout cas je n'étais
pas du tout pressé tu ne suis toujours
pas d'ailleurs de sortir du ministère de
l'éducation jeu je suis extrêmement
honoré de cesse que de ce qui m'a été
proposée par le président de république
il ya maintenant quatre ans en allemagne
et voilà après je considère que c'est
d'abord ça que je dois faire l'avenir on
verra bien et vous allez peut-être
rester aussi longtemps parce que vous
avez dit
[Applaudissements]
alors il y avait eu qu'un hidalgo qui va
se présenter au ministère de l'éducation
voilà payant et anne hidalgo a dit elle
a fait une proposition et voilà m alors
qu'aucun professeurs ou presque ne
demande autant forcément ça fait réagir
à la ligue fallait payer des professeurs
devaient être payés double avec l'argent
acquis avec l'oseille avec elle après
oui j'ai déjà dit que ça me paraît être
un peu le comble de la démagogie ce qui
est rarissime c'est tout simplement pas
faisable le calcul est simple c'est 150
milliards d'euros au cours du prochain
quinquennat donc c'est évidemment pas
possible que ça parce que c'est trompeur
je trouve que ce n'est pas respectueux
même vis-à-vis des principaux concernés
et les professeurs parce que
les gens ils savent que que c'est de la
démagogie oui je pourrais expliquer
pourquoi c'est parce qu'on en a tort on
aime on adore les professeurs et
instituteurs falloir les passants
soutien des professeurs ne sont pas
assez bien payés en france ça mais c'est
vrai le premier à dire d'ailleurs toute
la deuxième partie de moi et si ça vous
en parlait sur le sujet et donc nous
avons commencé avec un milliard
d'ailleurs le long de l'année prochaine
ce sera dans ses dernières heures oui
sur l'ensemble du quinquennat animations
il y a un truc est pas réalisable banon
quand d'abord ce que je dis à mes amis
dago c'est que dans le quinquennat
qu'elle a soutenu sa dé celui de
monsieur hollande il ya eu moins de
progression du pouvoir d'achat que dans
le quinquennat actuel nous avons plus
augmenter le budget de l'éducation
nationale donc déjà sur le plan des
preuves nous allons plus loin maintenant
on doit faire plus d'ailleurs à
l'échelle de la france mais c'est vrai
dans le monde entier dans les sociétés
du futur on a besoin du professeur on se
rend compte avec les ressentiments que
sera jamais remplacée par des robots par
des ordinateurs on a besoin de l'être
humain tout simplement et le professeur
est centrale pour l'avenir de nos pays
donc il doit être bien payé et donc en
effet il faut là où on va être d'accord
c'est qu'il faut augmenter les
professeurs rina et de manière qu'ils
disent à un clown et j'avais tellement
il était tombé dessus disait que c'était
n'importe quoi faire oui mais même quand
mélenchon l'a même jean luc mélenchon
l'a dit elle même elle laisse entendre
qu'elle prendra de l'argent ailleurs sur
la pénalité de l'argent
elle doit avoir une caisse noire pas
possible
alors on va parler aussi d'un autre
sujet c'est agnès buzyn
l'ancien ministre de la santé agnès
buzyn qui a été mise en examen pour mise
en danger de la vie d'autrui pour sa
gestion de l'épidémie aujourd'hui tout
le monde a parlé que de ça et c'est vrai
qu'on vous met face à la q celle actu du
jour quand vous voyez ça vous pensez
quoi de cette mise en examen alors on
n'a pas vocation en tant que responsable
politique a présenté les procédures
judiciaires mais ce qui est sûr c'est
que en démocratie on doit vraiment
dispagne et la responsabilité politique
et la responsabilité pénale la
responsabilité politique ça veut dire
rendre des comptes notamment devant
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat et
aussi devant les médias pour ex chéri ce
qu'on fait et c'est ce que nous faisons
et je pense qu'on est un des pays où il
ya eu le plus d'eau dit sion devant
l'assemblée nationale devant le sénat
moi même j'ai passé évidemment des
dizaines d'heures à expliquer ce que ce
que nous faisons c'est normal c'est ça
la démocratie et c'est ça la
responsabilité politique ce qui fait que
ben si le président le premier ministre
où la majorité pense que vous faites mal
votre travail vous sortez et puis aux
prochaines élections si vous l'avez mal
fait vous n'êtes pas réélu c'est ça la
responsabilité politique la
responsabilité judiciaire c'est quand
vous avez commis une faute une faute
grave donc évidemment voilà la
commission pour vous ne pas voir
d'autres ministres qui s'ils peuvent
être inquiétés ce que je peux dire c'est
que j'étais son collègue évidemment
pendant la période assez courte
finalement où elle était ministre de la
santé pendant le début de ce phénomène
j'ai vu au travail est extrêmement
attentive et bien sûr qu'elle voulait
bien faire et je pense que d'ailleurs il
ya certaines choses qu'elle a servi à
rien fait voir ça moi j'ai de l'amitié
pour ramener deux ans il avait appelé je
vais envoyer un message sur votre sapin
maintenant vous avez dit que voilà voilà
voilà penser à elle mais bien sûr
d'accord pour voilà l aféas l'a fait son
boulot et c'est voilà c'est ça la fait
ce qu'elle a pu oui encore une fois je
veux pas interférer avec avec une
procédure mais c'est juste que ce que je
vois ce que j'ai lu moi c'est une
personne de bonne volonté
cherchant à bien faire dans un moment où
dans le monde entier tous les ministres
de la santé dans la même situation
qu'elle c'est à dire arriver à découvrir
la meilleure approche de ce nouveau
phénomène à ouïr est monté bah c'est ça
l'histoire moi je ne comprends pas
pourquoi alors qu'elles sont mis en
examen c'est la démocratie a pas de
souci mais elle était ministre de la
santé au début où on connaissait rien de
cette crise elle ce qu'elle a fait il ya
bien quelqu'un qui lui a dit dire ça et
de faire ça donc maintenant qu'elles
soient mis en examen c'est bien mais il
ya d'autres gens qui sont aussi aux
gouvernements qui vont à ce moment là si
on dit des bêtises on fait des bêtises
au même titre cal qui devrait être aussi
en examen plus tard et des médecins qui
ont donné des mauvaises et du médecin
qu'on donnait des mauvaises informations
qui devraient être mises en examen peu
partout sauf au sommet
avaient pu deviner que le monde entier
elle est mis à l'arrêt bien sûr un virus
ne savait faux pas ce sont les fait
ressembler une part responsabilités
comme extrêmement les patients soient
refusés mais c'est ce que je suis en
train dé se soit elle le fusible opa
numérique et à d'autres questions pour
rapport pour le pour le ministre
willi quand j'avais une question beauté
c'est une autre question beauté noire
des habitations alain finkielkraut a
donné une interview dans le figaro
récemment où il disait qu aujourd'hui
finalement la réflexion ne passait plus
par la littérature par le littéraire
mais exclusivement par le scientifique
et finalement la connexion entre
la culture et la littérature était mort
et qu'aujourd'hui on avait accès
directement à la culture par la sara
jean-michel bloqués sms que vous êtes
d'accord avec cette thèse est ce qu'il
ya une contradiction dans le fait
qu'aujourd'hui on apprend les toits vont
venir
à lire sur un écran est ce que l'idée
d'apprendre à lire sur un écran ne
recoupe à la réfection de l'avenue
quelques routes s'il va falloir d'abord
il faut bien prévoir déjà
impressionnant on veut vraiment
rien qu'un fayot non pas d'une annonce
jean iv formula christian dans ma
réponse si alain finkielkraut disent
assez pour évidemment le déplorer c'est
à dire pour dire que moi d'accord avec
vos compères de la complexité dans notre
analyse des choses parce qu'on ne lit
plus assez les romans parce qu'on ne
rien plus assez pénétré de littérature
dessus prix là il a évoqué support on
change aussi ses deux compères le papier
au profit du numérique il a évidemment
raison d'avoir peur de ça parce qu'on
noit cendre ça moi je défends le livre
en particulier se défend le fait que les
enfants apprennent à lire sur des vitres
des vivres empaqueter d'un délire en
tissu à la maternelle rire et les et
qu'ils écrivent à la main vous savez il
ya eu des expériences aux états unis où
les où les élèves à la fin de ne
conserver que sur clavier jamais avec la
main et on a on en est revenu parce que
ça a beaucoup d'inconvénients si les
bill gates ont refusé que leurs enfants
utilisent des tablettes par exemple
parle par exemple oui tout à fait il ya
donc beaucoup de choses nous permettent
de relativiser le numérique donc il
s'agit pas de vivre sans numérique c'est
impossible et ça n'a pas de sens mais
c'est vrai qu'on doit le cantonais
incertain certains aspects donc par
exemple à l'école primaire c'est normal
qu'à certains moments il ya du numérique
ça peut être utile par exemple pour le
calcul mental ça peut être très utile
mais pour la lecture recommandons les
livres en papier bien sûr dana question
oui cyril disais tout à l'heure où vous
avez quelques réticences à l'idée de
venir à l'émission qu'est ce qui a fait
vous avez accepté finalement parce que
j'ai trouvé sympa voilà alors
une bonne question il est il est venu me
voir après le petit film qu'on a vu tout
à fait vrai c
mais enfin voila il m'a dit des choses
que j'ai trouvé c'est qu'on s'est parlé
juste du coup je n'avais aucune raison
de refuser une envie cette hargne et on
est à sens bien ma maman
bowling tout ça ah oui dernière question
est sérieuse
pour de vrai j'ai dernière extrêmement
choqué par le fait que le président
était giflé par quelqu'un je crois que
cette personne a pris 14 mois de prison
larry va avec je cours en plus avec
sursis c'est à dire absolument rien je
trouve que c'est une honte est ce que
vous êtes choqués par cette décision
j'ai été choqué par le fait que le
président macro et dit ce jour là c'est
rien c'est pas très grave or c'est très
très grave un président qui ait frappé
dans un pays c'est tout le pays qui est
touché est ce qu'on aurait fait ça avec
trump à ce qu'on aurait fait ça avec un
autre président est ce que vous trouvez
vraiment aller même accro à la posture
d'un président il n'a pas été respectée
pendant son quinquennat non je pense
qu'au contraire il ay l'a fait il a
respecté d'une certaine façon la
séparation des pouvoirs quand il fait ça
c'est à dire il est l'autorité
judiciaire faire cela et il a au
contraire il ya une forme de hauteur de
vue c'est à dire et dit finalement
appartement où ces faits ça ne devient
plus mon sujet ça devient un sujet que
le juge va estimer dans son indépendance
lui après au contraire je pense qu'à une
noblesse de son approche mais en même
temps ce que vous dites est très juste
c'est grave c'est pas c'est pas un fait
anodin mais je trouve que sa réaction la
radio oui mais c'est parce que vous
réagissez de façon noble que vous qu'un
que précisément vous vous allez à
l'encontre de ce qui a pu faire la
personne à ces dernières pour le elle
veut vous abaissez en faisant ça elle la
personne veut abaisser la fonction et en
réagissant de cette façon là ilan oublie
la fonction précisément par exemple
gérer par d'autres mais l'enjeu si vous
vivez un président de la république upr
autres personnes de ce pays vous prenez
quatre mois de prison non mais surtout
il ya quand même un procès pénal et
c'est grave bien sûr merci jean michel
blanquer d'avoir été avec nous